okay so ms marvel episode 1 is now out
on disney plus and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking it down
talking about the easter eggs in it and
also going over how it links into the
comics though the powers have been
changed up massively for the character
this is arguably the most comic book
accurate disney plus show that we've
ever had it's extremely in line with the
graphic novel by g willow wilson titled
no normal several things pull from it
however the biggest departure is kamala
khan's powers which are completely
different to how they are in the comics
in the source material she's pretty much
a shape-shifter that can make parts of
her body change out well the reason she
even got the name ms marvel in the first
place was because after she became
infected with terrigen mist she
shape-shifted to look like captain
marvel in her older costume she ended up
saving zoey a character from the show
and after the news reported on this the
name kinda stuck now ms marvel in the
comics can make herself her hands or her
body larger but yeah she's got powers
more in line with a character like green
lantern in the series she wears what i
believe are nega bands which are
powerful relics from the kree empire
these were gifted to captain marvel by
the supreme intelligence and they ended
up trapping him in the negative zone at
one point we see kamala travel through
this and it's gonna be interesting to
see if it's brought up further down the
line as we don't really have a villain
per se after this first entry i think
we'll also track down the origin of them
and this will likely be where we lead
into the marvels which we know is an
upcoming film starring the character
captain marvel and also photon now he
opened with kamala khan's life as a
youtuber in the comics she wrote fan
fiction but here they changed it up to
make it so that she's down with the kids
who happen to be 33 years old stay off
my patch
if it is good though and if i was
watching it well on any youtube video
i'd definitely like comment and
subscribe cheers now we hear the song
blinding lights by the weekend and i
hope she didn't put this in the video
otherwise she's gonna get slapped with a
big copyright claim you damn chump see
ya chump
now this recounts the battle at the end
of avengers end game and it features
okoye black panther thor steve rogers
hulk and also iron man we can also catch
hawkeye in a purple and white crosshair
whilst he wears his new costume like in
the comics he's blonde and this purple
and white style was part of the map
fraction run which also inspired the
style of the series cap shield is broken
like how it was in the film but rather
than being split in half it has this
pizza slice out of it like the one that
appeared in the vision during age of
ultron as we pan out we also see peppa
potts in the rescue suit valkyrie a tiny
ant-man and also wonder we then get a
quick shot of a cockatoo which was a
bird that actually played into the
villain reveal at the end of the first
graphic novel guess who loves a cockatoo
ryanairy's mom chapao but i'm not a
rapper now next we catch an air force
jet before the arrival of captain marvel
captain marvel was of course a pilot
before she became a cree warrior and
amongst the pictures of her we can also
see all the costumes on the wall there's
also mention of the scotland podcast
which is titled big me little me she
destroys the sanctuary 2 like in the
movie and changes her hairstyle as she
lands alternating between the one from
her solo film and also end game we can
also see that one of the ships has
circle q on it which is the name of a
convenience store her pal bruno works at
this is the same place he was at in the
comics and kamala ended up stopping a
robbery there carried out by his brother
thanos arrives and he's wearing a crown
possibly riffing on the rickross fan art
that was created of him she's the one
who's seen as beating thanos by kamala
and she talks about her going back into
space to who knows where kamala
announces she's going to avengers con as
marvel and this is basically the plot
device that the first episode is center
around that gets her her powers in the
comics it was just a party in a field
that she was told she couldn't go to and
her classmates ended up putting vodka in
some orange juice upon realizing she was
drinking alcohol she spat it out and
then headed home here the territory
misrolled in and she had a vision of the
avengers fighting on planet unicorn this
is presented in a comic bookie style
similar to the opening here carol also
wears an army jacket at this just like
what she has in the source material
kamala then says a line about thor next
week i'm gonna kick off a special
two-part series on why i think thor is
secretly a gamer now as we learned in
endgame the guy has a bit of rivalry
with new master 69 so you might be onto
something there now she's got faster
upload speed than me and she posts this
on her channel titled sloth baby
productions sloth baby was also a
moniker she took in the comics and you
can buy can buy t-shirts with that on if
you want or you can waste your money on
my t-shirts instead now amongst her vids
i get no views
you also have ant-man in the wasps
romantic vacation where they fly on top
of an ant with a beret in paris five
years in two weeks
see a chump there's also a video called
bitten by a radioactive feminist riffing
on how peter parker got his spider
powers and possibly possibly poking fun
outbreak lawson here we meet the khan
family which has a similar setup to what
was in the comics her brother amir is
praying and this scene downstairs pretty
much plays out exactly as how it is in
the source material really nice
attention to detail here and it leads
into her driving test in which she wears
aviators further calling back to her
idol you also get a sign for jersey city
which cements here is being based in the
same place as a comic book counterpart
there's a really nice art style to this
whole show and though i know it's a
teeny type of mcu entry i think the
editing and animation is some of the
most creative stuff we've had in the
franchise yes i'm shilling heavy
shillings all day baby now after
crashing the car she's taken home but
she daydreams seeing captain marvel as
she looks over the new york skyline cut
to jersey city high school and we get a
note of the creative team on a plaque
there this includes g willow wilson the
writer of the first miss marvel graphic
novel who ends up also getting brought
into being a character through mr wilson
her name's pronounced
camellia which
kevin feige he didn't he didn't even get
the pronunciation right sometimes but
there's also kids that stand in front of
her locker and then we meet bruno before
running into nakia both of these are
characters in the comics that we were
introduced to in the opening panels at
circle q here we also came across zoe
zimmer who too pops up in this scene zoe
was a sort of bully but she did it by
being really nice and sort of lacing it
with sarcasm which i bloody hate now she
ends up dressing as captain marvel i'm
being sarcastic by the way now she ends
up dressing up as capta as you can tell
now she ends up dressing as captain
marvel at the end of the episode but the
comics changed things up quite a lot
upon transforming into miss marvel
kamala ended up saving zoey from
drowning after the party and this is
when people came across it mr wilson
poses the question of who she is
something that we will no doubt ponder
in the series and they even split the
screen to foreshadow the split between
herself and her alter ego desperate to
get to avengers con she and bruno work
on her costume and we get the inner
layout of circle q which seems like it's
raped right out of the comics as they
try and come up with her final flourish
we get artwork nodes to steampunk and
potentially infinity warps in the comics
this was a mashup of characters such as
the soldiers supreme that basically took
two famous ones and mushed them together
we get mentions of iron marvel captain
panther and dr strange marvel who
appears with several arms similar to his
battle with thanos as mentioned of thor
on valkyrie as well as the rainbow
bridge aka the pie frost we then get
zombie captain marvel which is of course
playing on marvel zombies at this point
kamala gets a box from her grandma which
contains the bands we discover that she
deliberately wanted to pass things on to
her granddaughter potentially teasing at
her having powers herself her mother
maniva sees these and takes them off her
possibly hitting at her knowing what
they hold along the way we see lots of
nods to pakistani culture and even
several bangles on a mural which were
the inspiration for the ten ring sheng
chi used i know it's part of pakistani
culture as well but just pointing out
the similarities and sorry for sounding
ignorant-ish now kamala tries on bridal
dresses and we hear a story about
another girl who ended up traveling to
europe instead of getting married kamala
is really rebellious and the main
criticism i've seen for the show is that
it's pretty much the pushy parent slash
rebellious kid stereotype this kind of
pushes her into going to avengers con
and in the comics it was what drove her
going to the party however upon having
alcohol she felt guilty over letting her
parents down which is why she left to go
home she asks her parents if she can go
to the con and her t-shirt has the girls
get it done scene from avengers end game
on it they have a really cool texting
back and forth scene with kamala and
bruno and some of the graphics are
really well thought out it all happens
in one shot and they integrate the
emojis really well into the environment
in my opinion now in bruno's room we see
a picture for nikola tesla a famous
inventor who inspired bruno to work on
photon gloves for kamala later he sits
on a roof with kamala and behind them we
can see a sign for edison electric
another rival of tesla who would
probably steal all my easter eggs if he
was a youtuber today he stole me bloody
easter eggs now in the comics the
villain she faced stuff against sterling
was a clone of thomas edison created by
gregory knox he attempted to recreate
the inventor but accidentally mix the
sample with bird dna this could tie back
to the intro and i don't want to get old
mephisto again but the clues that he yes
he
he's the big bad
that the clues are there i'm telling you
either way we also get a locker room
scene and this is likely riffing on the
one from the source material now in her
room there's also a poster for captain
marvel above a mirror which is official
promo art for the first movie this riffs
on the actual post that she had in her
room that she looked to at several
points she also wraps the sash around
her waist which is something that pulls
from the source material now at this
point her parents suggest she dresses up
as the hulk and her dad busts in as the
giant green guy cgi it looks better than
she-hulk to be fair her kamala is gifted
the photon gloves and this is of course
playing on photon aka maria rambo nice
that she was nice to wander after west
view and then she went to another
universe and killed her mother yay
kamala comes up with a plan on how to
leave her parents which again is
animated really well we see in this
fantasy that her parents think she's the
best daughter ever and that her costume
is now like captain marvel's one in the
movies rather than some crappy leather
jacket bruno in the fantasy is dressed
as tony stark and he also has the
repulsor glove on that he used to fight
buggy with in civil war we discovered
that avenger con is at camp lee high the
home of captain america when we last saw
this it was an avengers end game however
going off the timeline it also appeared
in the winter soldier which is where it
was destroyed by a missile being fixed
up now and as they got on the bus we see
someone dressed up as one of the chorus
girls from the star-spangled man with a
plan this song is later played when we
get to the event and as i've been saying
it's all connected now here we go into
some instagram posts full of characters
i watched these at 0.25 x speed and i'm
actually i'm actually copywriting that
saying so if anyone if you see anyone
using that phrase that they watch
something at 0.25 x speed then they owe
me 25 million dollars i'm just kidding
yeah shout out to canadian lad he's a
bloody lovely guy spoke to him a couple
of times and what a nice chap now
amongst these are an ant-man some of the
dancers from the start of iron man 2 is
also a vision black widow and female
thor her winning reminds me a lot of the
cover lived through this by whole but
obviously pageant moments like this are
laced throughout films and tv shows now
bruno suggests she injects some of
herself into the costume and this is
when she gets the bands from the attic
we see her original captain america
comic that she drew when she was younger
and she gets the bands the day of the
con arrives and after losing her bike we
get countless cosplayers and not only is
there a statue of captain america we
also see someone dressed as him in bucky
rocket raccoon the hulk wasp mantis drax
and a wakandan king also show up in this
moment inside there are models of
ant-man and a cut out of iron man along
with black widow there's also someone is
doctor strange gamora thor with a guy
wearing cds for his arm and a lot more
we get flashes of groot thor dancers a
notice steve rogers being america's ass
an ant-man figure and helmet as well as
a mural for tony and natasha there's not
one for vision as he died during
infinity war five years prior and steve
rogers is thought to have gone to the
moon rather than being dead there's also
a female captain america that could be
peggy carter but due to the star shield
rather than the union jack i think it's
based on steve there's also asgard pride
and the asgardians of course had to
settle on earth after their home was
destroyed we also see a leaflet for us
guardian tours which judging off the
love and thunder trailer will be
something that pops up in that movie we
then get a winter soldier monument with
steve wearing black similar to the fan
art for the film next we see a man
dressed as anthony from ant-man before
watching a mock-up of the san francisco
ship scene from ant-man and the wasp
there's also trash pandas on sale at the
guardian station and the peter quill
starboy story she then sees zoe dressed
as marvel and though the costume isn't
seen as accurate it is in line with the
comics this is similar to the 70s miz
marvel costume with the mcu colors
behind here we also see cut outs of
strange and wonder on opposite sides
which would end up happening in
multiverse of madness and yes it's a
reach now kamala takes to the stage and
at this point bruno dresses as bruce
banner because bruce banner bruno
never mind
now kamala's powers manifest on stage
after she puts on the bangles and the
crowd they go bloody wild she destroys
the ant-man exhibit nearly kills loads
of kids but it's the best time anyone's
ever had
now lastly it drops the sculpt of
mollier her final destination zoe and
similar to the comics kamala saves her
life she makes a break for it to get
home and she comes across her mother
who's been waiting up for her she's not
mad she's just disappointed and that
ends the episode and the credits are
filled with references to the comic book
covers ms marvel is featured on and it's
a really nice way to call back to the
source material before we head into the
post-credits scene from here we catch
back up with the department of damage
control who we last saw in spider-man no
way home back once more is agent p
cleary played once more by arien moyet
when we last saw him he was arresting
he's arresting
someone
can't quite remember who but the point
is that he's back now we also see the
interrogation room from nowhere home and
after witnessing kamala's powers they
decide it's time to bring her in anyway
that's the end of the first episode
and it was fine wasn't it i don't think
it really did anything outstanding
outside of the animation but you know
this probably isn't aimed at me so i
think its target audience will probably
find it more enjoyable than i did i
didn't think it was bad yet before you
start not bad by a long stretch but it
was a bit by the numbers and i do kind
of wonder where they can really take
this show the comic run is pretty good
though and they seem to be sticking
close to that so we'll likely get a
coming-of-age story with a couple of
curveballs thrown in there anyway i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts was it
a hit or was it a miss marvel hey
comment below and let me know and i'll
probably miss a lot of easter eggs
that'll be in better videos than this
one so
go find them out yeah come back here and
you'll look really smart much smarter
than me now we are in competition right
now and as a thank you for doing that
you'll you'll you'll get a prize yeah
you could get the prize of getting the
batman on the 15th of june all you have
to do to be when the chance of winning
is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the boys which will be
linked on screen right now not really
the same demographic as this but they do
have they do have a festival seen in it
which you know is a bit similar to this
con so go ahead over there and uh have
some fun with it if not then thanks for
sitting through the video i've been paul
let's see in the next one take care
peace